reflections on the color of my skin
Wednesday June 3rd 2020
at a physics conference I attended long
ago while sipping wine leftover from the
final dinner a dozen of us peeled off
and started arguing about fun geeky
things like why does Superman need a
cape
why do cans of Diet Pepsi float while
cans of regular Pepsi sink and how would
the Star Trek transporter actually work
as the evening progressed just after a
discussion of momentum transfer and car
accidents one of us mentioned a time
when the police stopped him while
driving the officer ordered him from his
sports car and conducted a thorough
search of his body the car's cabin and
the trunk before sending him home on his
way with a hefty ticket the charge for
stopping him driving 20 miles per hour
over the local speed limit try as we did
we could not muster sympathy for his
cause my colleague had other encounters
with the law that he shared later that
night but his first story started a
chain reaction among us
one by one we each recall multiple
incidents of being stopped by the police
none of the accounts were particularly
violent or life-threatening although it
was easy to extrapolate to highly
publicized cases that were one of my
colleagues had been stopped for driving
too slowly he was admiring the local
flora as he drove through a New England
town in the autumn another had been
stopped because he was speeding but only
by five miles per hour he was questioned
and then released without getting a
ticket
still another colleague had been stopped
and questioned for jogging down the
street late at night as for me I had a
dozen different encounters to draw from
there was the time I was stopped late at
night at an underpass on an empty road
in New Jersey for having changed lanes
without signaling the officer told me to
get out of my car and questioned me for
ten minutes around back with the
headlights of his squad car frankly
illuminating my face is this your car
yes who's the woman in the passenger
seat my wife where are you coming from
my parents house where are you going
home what do you do for a living I'm an
astrophysicist at Princeton University
what's in your trunk a spare tire and a
lot of other greasy junk he went on to
say that the real reason why he stopped
me was because my car's license plates
were much newer and shinier than the
17-year old Ford that I was driving the
officer was just making sure that
neither the car nor the plates were
stolen
among my other stories I had been
stopped by campus police while
transporting my home supply of physics
textbooks into my newly assigned office
in graduate school they had stalked me
at the entrance to the physics building
where they had asked accusatory
questions about what I was doing it was
11:30 p.m. open topped boxes of graduate
math and physics textbook filled the
trunk and I was transporting them into
the building which left me wondering how
often that scenario shows up in a police
training video
we went on for two more hours but before
we retired for the night we searched for
common denominators among the stories we
had all driven different cars some were
old some were new some were
undistinguished others were
high-performance imports some police
stops were in the daytime others were at
night taken one by one each encounter
with the law could be explained as an
isolated incident where in modern times
we all must forfeit some freedoms to
ensure a safer society for us all taken
collectively however you would think the
cops had a vendetta against physicists
because that was the only profile we all
had in common in this parade of
automotive stop and frisks one thing was
for sure the stories were not singular
novel moments playfully recounted they
were common recurring episodes how could
this assembly of highly educated
scientists each in possession of the PhD
the highest academic degree in the land
be so vulnerable to police inquiry in
their lives maybe the police queued on
something else maybe it was the color of
our skin the conference I had been
attending was the 23rd meeting of the
National Society of black physicists we
were guilty not of DWI driving while
intoxicated but of other violations none
of us knew were on the books dwb driving
while black WWB walking while black and
of course jbb just being black none of
us were beaten senseless none of us were
shot but what does it take for a police
encounter to turn lethal
on average police in America kill more
than 100 unarmed black people per year
who never made it to her circle
I suspect our multi-hour conversation
would be rare among most groups of
law-abiding people
as I composed this about 10,000 chanting
protestors are filing past my window in
Manhattan and because of the
intermittent looting and related
violence the curfew for this evening has
been pushed earlier to 8 p.m. from 11
p.m. and preceding days the most common
placard was black lives matter many
others displayed the name George Floyd
who was handcuffed face down on the
street with a police officers knee in
the back of his neck applied with a
force of at least half the officers body
weight resulting in his death curious
irony that NFL star Colin Kaepernick
offered a simple demonstration of care
and concern for the fate of black people
in the custody of police officers he
simply took a knee during the
star-spangled banner before football
games one media outlet mangled the
moment by describing him as protesting
the national anthem itself the outrage
against his silent act of concern for a
national problem persisted through the
2017 season when as a free agent he went
unsigned by any team to continue his
livelihood so he went from a peaceful
knee on the ground to a fatal knee on
the neck
the way peaceful protesters and the
press are being shoved maced tear gassed
pepper sprayed and tackled in the
streets of our cities when the police
should really focus on arresting the
looters you would think that protesters
were doing something illegal or
unamerican
but of course the US Constitution has
something to say about that Congress
shall make no law abridging the freedom
of the press or the right of the people
peaceably to assemble and to petition
the government for a redress of
grievances
which amendment was that the first
amendment so the founders of this nation
felt quite strongly about it as such
protesting for redress of grievances is
one of the most American things you can
do if you are the police pause and
reflect how great is the country whose
constitution endorses peaceful protests
what do we actually expect from our
police officers to protect the peace and
a rest the bad guys I presume but also
to be armed with lethal force that they
can use when necessary that part clearly
requires training on how and when to use
and not use the power of your weapons
the rigorous minneapolis police academy
training lasts for months the slightly
more rigorous New York City police
academy lasts six months
yet to become a certified pastry chef at
a prestigious Culinary Academy requires
eight months I guess the perfect cross
song needs it so maybe just maybe police
recruits could benefit from a bit more
training before becoming officers in
1991 Rodney King age 25 was struck
dozens of times while on the ground by
four LAPD officers with their batons
after being tased the grainy 1990s video
of the incident went media viral
inducing shock and dismay to any viewer
but I wasn't shocked at all based on
what I already knew of the world my
first thought was we finally got one of
those on tape followed by maybe justice
will be served this time yes that's
precisely my first thought why since
childhood my parents instilled in me and
my siblings via monthly sometimes weekly
lessons rules of conduct to avoid
getting shot by the police make sure
that when you're stopped the officer can
always see both of your hands no sudden
movements don't reach into your pockets
for anything without announcing this in
advance when you move at all
tell the officer what you're about to do
at the time I'm a budding scientist in
middle school just trying to learn all I
can about the universe
I hardly ever think about the color of
my skin it never comes up when
contemplating the cosmos yet when I exit
my front door I'm a crime suspect
add to this the recently coined
white-collar crime we're scared white
people call the police
because they think an innocent black
person is doing something non innocent
and it's a marvel that any of us achieve
at all
the rate of abuse between one and five
skin color instigated incidents per week
for every week of my life
why people must have known explicitly
it's not implicitly of this struggle why
else with the infamous phrase I'm free
white and 21 even exist there's a
compliation of that line used in films
across the decades yes
it's offensive but in America it's also
truthful today's often denied white
privilege accusation was back then often
declared the deadly LA riots associated
with the Rodney King incident are often
remembered as a response to the beating
but now Los Angeles was quiet for 13
months afterward everyone had confidence
as did I that the video was just the
kind of evidence needed to finally bring
about a conviction in the abuse of power
but that's not what came to pass the
riots were a response to the acquittal
of the four officers in the incident and
not to the incident itself and what is a
riot if not the last act of helpless
desperation the 1989 film by Spike Lee
do the right thing which explored 1980s
black white police tensions in Brooklyn
New York ended with a dedication to the
families of six people
Eleanor bumpers aged 66
Michael Griffith aged 23 Arthur Miller
aged 30 Edmund Perry aged 17
Yvonne Smallwood aged 28 and Michael
Stewart aged 25 all are black one was
killed by a white mob the rest were
unarmed and shot by police or otherwise
died while in police custody all deaths
occurred within ten years preceding the
film and all occurred in New York City
none of the police induced deaths
resulted in convictions as continues to
be true for
99% of all police killings
we know of these events because they
each ended in death but even so back
then it was only local news was this
just New York City's problem I asked
myself I also wondered for every police
related death anywhere
how many unarmed victims are shot by
police and don't die or are wrongfully
maimed or injured most of those cases
didn't even make the local news but if
you lived in those neighborhoods you
knew we all knew for what it's worth New
York City now has the lowest police
caused death rate per capita among the
60 largest cities in the United States
could it be because of those extra two
months in the New York police academy
the corrosion and ultimate erosion of
our confidence in the legal system in
cases such as these even in the face of
video evidence has spawned a tsunami of
protests with sympathetic demonstrations
across the United States and around the
world if the threat of prison time for
this behavior does not exist acting as a
possible deterrent then the behavior
must somehow stop on its own some
studies show that the risk of death for
an unarmed person at the hands of the
police is approximately the same no
matter the demographics of who gets
arrested okay but if your demographic
gets stopped 10 times more than others
then your demographic will die at 10
times the rate
but even after we get the bias factor
down to zero there's still the matter of
police killing unarmed suspects white
people included I talk a lot but I don't
talk much about any of this or events
along these paths of most resistance
that have shaped me why because
throughout my life I've used these
occasions as launch points to succeed
even more yes i parlay the persistent
rejections of society which today might
be called microaggressions into
reservoirs of energy to achieve I
learned that from My Father himself
active in the civil rights movement
during the 1950s and 1960s in a way I am
Who I am
precisely because countless people by
their actions or inactions said I would
never be what I became but what becomes
of you if you don't possess this deep
supply of fuel who from historically
disenfranchised communities including
women LGBTQ and anybody of color is
missing falling shy of their potential
because they ran out of energy and gave
up trying are things better today than
yesterday yes but one measure of this
truth is a bit perverse decades ago
unarmed black people getting beaten or
killed by the police
barely merited the local news but now
it's national news even breaking news no
matter where in the country it occurs so
how do you change all this organizations
have surely put forth demands for police
departments here I offer a list of my
own for policy experts to consider one
extend police academies to include
months of cultural awareness and
sensitivity training that also includes
how not to use lethal force to all
police officers should be tested for any
implicit bias they carry with
established
thresholds of acceptance and rejection
from the police academy
we all carry bias but most of us do not
hold the breathing lives of others in
our hands when influenced by it 3 during
protests protect property protect lives
if you attack nonviolent protesters you
are being unamerican and we wouldn't
need draconian curfews if police
arrested looters instead of protesters 4
if fellow officers are behaving in a way
that is clearly unethical or excessively
violent and you witness this please stop
them someone will get that on video
offering the rest of us confidence that
you can police yourselves in these cases
our trust in you matters more to a civil
society that how much you stick up for
each other 5 and here is a radical idea
for the Minneapolis Police Department
why not give George Floyd the kind of
full dress funeral you give each other
for dying in the line of duty and vow
that such a death will never happen
again 6 lastly when you see black kids
in the street think of what they can be
rather than what you think they are
respectfully submitted Neil deGrasse
Tyson New York City
trying hard to keep looking up
you